why should we care about the fall of the
Berlin Wall well first of all because it
meant that the Iron Curtain was coming
down as well and in that grade the air
of 1989 which was called the year of
miracles all over Eastern and Central
Europe whether it was Poland or
Czechoslovakia or hungry and then
finally of course in East Germany people
were free for the first time in 40 years
well back in January 1890 my wife and I
were having brunch one Sunday and this
was two months after the wall had come
down and I said well already people are
beginning to forget about Communists I'm
already there being afraid well why it
fell why it collapsed they're beginning
to forget about the victims of
Communists who we knew were in the tens
of millions and and said to me you know
what we need we need a memorial to the
victims of communism and I scribbled
that down in a piece of paper stuck in
my pocket and the next morning which was
Monday I began making calls and we were
off from there with the idea of having a
memorial to all the victims of communism
which now number we know according to
the black book of communism about 100
million I mean there was no freedom
there was no freedom of speech no
freedom of religion and freedom of
thought people couldn't write a poem or
a play or a story or conduct a
scientific experiment without some
sensor first approving it all of that
story has to be told the difficulty for
the media is aware of the pictures and
that of course is one of the reasons why
we're very excited about the Gulag
collection because it is a visual story
of the Gulag painted by nikolai Getman
who was a political prisoner from 1945
to 1953
there he was in far-distant siberia
degrees were 30 and 40 degrees below
zero and they worked outside in those
there their diet consisted of a couple
of pieces of bread the size of your fist
and some thin gruel they slept on wooden
bunks with mattresses which were filled
with straw and yet he did survive he was
a professional artist and he came out
and said you know I want to remember
those people who were with me in the
their sacrifice should not be in vain or
forgotten so I'm going to start doing
what I do best which is to do series of
paintings and so for the next 40 years
he painted these haunting works of in
secret from memory capturing and
recapturing those does those terrible
days of pain and suffering and death
it's an extraordinary thing that he was
able to survive and yet to capture I
think so brilliantly and hauntingly
these paintings they're on exhibit here
through December they will then were
thinking about a traveling exhibition
and then we will look for a permanent
home for this collection
hopefully in a bricks-and-mortar Museum
here in Washington DC for the victims of
communism and their memory and their
sacrifice the Cold War was something
that we fought for 45 years and I think
that as we look back upon that event
that great event we have to resolve that
never again well peoples and nations
allow so evil a tyranny to terrorize the
world
you